now as a consequence of the close graph
being zero at those two points what's
going to happen to the tan graph if your
cause graphed your denominator is zero
what does that mean for tan some of
you've already drawn the shape so you
know you've got it right there starts
with an A so to say a lot of home you
can asymptote right because you can't
exist when you're dividing by zero so if
you haven't already go through and put
in your asymptote at PI on two as well
as at three PI on to okay like so quick
show of hands who's drawn their time
graph okay about babsy that's fine for
the rest of you let's have a go at the
rest of it we're gonna start down low
and then we're going to come up towards
the asymptote like so okay now at this
point I'm going to remind you that every
single trigonometric function that
you're graphing it has a period right it
repeats it's got this frequency right
what's the period what's the length that
it takes for the sine or cosine graph to
repeat itself to get a full copy
it's said again how many radians it's
two pi right from 0 to 2pi and then you
just start the same thing over again ten
though is different this period is not 2
pi what's its period it's it's half of
that it's pi so here's 0 pi is over here
right so from 0 to pi you get the same
shape just copied over right so this
shape that we just drew here it's going
to repeat like so okay and if I went
another PI radians over I would get
another copy ok but I'm lazy I'm just
doing it here what is the other half
I've drawn half of the tan graph now
what is the other half look like yeah
yeah perfect it's that same shape isn't
it but it's actually reflected back that
way in fact we've got rotational
symmetry on the whole graph so if you go
ahead do that same shape there and you
copy it 180 degrees over okay or pi
radians and we'll put our values on here
0 2 pi are you guys happy with that tan
graph y equals 10
X happy max you see a thumbs up thank
you anyone else happy
I think it looks good too but I think
it's missing something I think it's
missing one small thing can anyone think
of what this might be missing say it
again the one in the negative one the
one of a negative one why did I have one
a negative one on these graphs why did
we put them in yeah there's a visit
there's a finish to the graph isn't it
as an endpoint right does the tan graph
have an endpoint no just it just goes
forever
what's our language for this by the way
our you're doing this thing with your
arms we're talking about domain before
this is domain what's this thing range
very good so you got a range here
negative 1 to 1 you've got a range here
negative 1 to 1 what's the range for
this yeah we can write this in two ways
we can write it in interval notation or
we can write it with set notation okay
so we could say for this one here I'm
going to get rid of my bad graph now
okay so our range here this one we would
write it as let's see we could say
negative 1 to 1
what's the way we would do this with
interval notation by the way you'd
remember it negative 1 yes square
bracket on the left
come on positive 1 and then another
square bracket okay same thing for this
this is the same graph but here right
our range well if we wrote this in
interval notation it's gonna be someone
said negative infinity right and all the
way to positive infinity what do I have
on the outside
do I have square brackets I'm gonna have
curly brackets why why curved ecobee
records yeah you can't ever you kind of
get there as a final thing right that's
in interval notation how would I write
that using this yeah all real values of
Y you could write it like that if you
didn't want to use the word or real
values of Y all right now the reason I'm
highlighting this is number one you need
to remember at number two negative 1 and
1 I'm not as important to this graph as
they are to these two right now I still
think that's actually a really good idea
and I want you to remember why can you
tell me you don't have to draw this but
just look at it ok can you please tell
me firstly what's the name of that kind
of graph start with an H it's a
hyperbola very good hyperbole now that
you know remember it's a hyperbola can
someone tell me the equation of that
hyperbola 1 over X 1 over X 2 agrees 1
over X is that a hyperbola is 1 over X a
hyperbola yes it is it absolutely is but
how did we know that this hyperbola was
1 over X n not for example 2 over X or 3
over X or 5 billion over X how did you
know yeah well you're right I've left
off my asymptotes which are here and
here but guess what
even with those asymptotes this still
could be 1 over X or 2 over X or
whatever over X yeah I'm looking for how
much it bends right now the problem with
this is sorry guys
I'm just totally trolling you you don't
know how much it bends you need one of
these what we call them again it's a
point that tells you what about the
graph if I told you this was for example
1 1 now what do you know you know the
scale now yes we call this a point for
scale if I change this to 1 comma 2 now
it's a different graph ok so come back
to our 10 graph we need to put something
on to you because this could be 10 X it
could be something else what else could
it be
what other equation could have it really
could have a whole bunch what do we do
to this I could multiply it by a number
yeah I could stretch it out vertically
and everything on the graph that you've
drawn would look the same this would
still be not this would still be pilots
still with you by asymptotes would all
be in the same spots ok so here's I'm
going to ask you to do get your rule
or if you've got grid paper this is
handy but number one something you might
not have grid paper number two you make
a grid paper in the HSC so you best not
get too reliant on it
get your ruler out and then I'd love you
to measure the difference the distance
rather on your graph from zero to your
first asymptote from zero to two pi can
you measure that for me now once you've
measured it i should measure mine mine
is just a bit under ten centimeters so
once you've got that distance I want you
to have it can you have that distance
run color have it there okay now what
was the equation of that first asymptote
can someone tell me the equation of the
first asymptote along I'll give you a
clue starts with an x equals x equals
what what's the value it's a pile on to
right so if we've just halved that
distance what's my orange coordinate my
x corner there PI on for its half of
that now I picked plan for very
deliberately if you haven't already got
your calculator there right get your
calculator and just to make sure you're
convinced because we did this variety of
ways but this is just one of the
quickest ones you might have won't
remember make sure your calculator is in
radians put into the right mode and then
I'd love you to please put in for me tan
of piyo and for what do you get
make sure your radians that's ten to
forty five degrees which maybe is one R
does that trigger memory that's one
right so now that value there is one
okay so rather than just like pick a
value somewhere vertically and say I
hope that's one right one happens at a
specific spot PI on four just like this
is a spot you've got to know high on two
and one this is what you've also got a
note planned for and one you can use
your calculator to help you but you've
got to know it somehow okay